we received information about
those who died yesterday in yesterday's
bombardment of maternity hospital and
children's hospital in mariopol we lost
three people among them one child a girl
the amount of wounded is 17 these are
children
women and medical
employees
you know
russian tv mentioned this subject uh
during a talk show but they didn't say a
single word of truth the russians were
lied that
claiming there were no patients in the
hospital and no children or
women in the maternity hospital the
russians were lied that uh
claiming that uh nationalists uh took up
a position there they're confidently
lying as always
crimes of war impossible without
propagandist covering them i want to
tell them them one thing you will be
responsible
same way as those who give orders to
drop bombs
on the peaceful civilians yesterday we
received
new information about those people who
managed to get out to
non-occupied territory
on top of those who didn't uh manage to
leave before night and continued
evocating in the morning we managed to
save to evacuate more than 60 000 of our
people for us what is important this
specific specific subjects and words in
our relations with the countries of
western europe we're fighting for our
independence for equality
for all in the continent
that's why we want to see
decisions from our partners those who
are based on the reality
rather than on declarations or abstract
observations